Kyle Kolinsky is an actual disgusting piece of >> like
just a genuinely disgusting piece >> literally says you,
buddy. Says you. He's like barely engaging with what's going
on. He's just like, "There's so many people on Twitter who are
saying things I don't like and I have to take the opposite position
of them." Hutch is actually just going to try to submarine as
many Dems as he can. This is so funny.
[music]
Where's [music] the Where's my Hutch timestamps? Where's my Hutch
timestamps at? Where are they at? So, this is the Lindsay whatever
post. Okay, so what we found out yesterday was that this Lindsay
Five, the Lindsay Field woman is the source of the original Kfile
investigation.
So, what happened here is back in October, Lindsay reached out
to Jewish Insider with these logs of her telling somebody in
August, which is around the time that the campaign found out
about the tattoo and that it might have Nazi origins. She reached
out to a friend and said, "Oh, well, Graham's running for office.
He might be running for office and he has a Nazi tattoo." Okay,
so that timing is very sus. The way they present it in the K
file stuff and the way a lot of people present it is if the t
as if the it's as if the messages are from years ago. They're
not from years ago. They're from like a month or two before
the campaign acknowledged it. Okay. Then that gets taken to CNN,
Andrew Kazinski. They go and verify that she did send the text
back in August, but they say that it's a a decade old acquaintance.
Okay.
Then the New York Times story breaks. The New York Times story
is running with his ex-girlfriend who is the primary person describing
abuse from Graham Platner.
Basically like the headliner of the article. Okay.
What they don't make clear is that the my token cop stuff, she
she validates the my token cop stuff, but they don't make it
clear that when that was originally reported, it was her who
told that story as well. So what it looks like is it's a validation
of that previous story. And what they can leave out when they
when they tell it this way is the fact that when that story didn't
sink his campaign,
he then came out with abuse allegations.
That doesn't mean it's impossible that he was physically abusive,
but it certainly makes it given everything else, given the lack
of corroboration, incredibly difficult to stomach these and and
see them as anything but a like a smear, right? like that she
explicitly
explicitly has tried twice now to submarine his campaign as an
ex who described him as like her the worst thing that ever happened
to her like there was a lot of animist there. Okay,
and I think this is journalistic malpractice to not actually
make this clear the whole way through. So Andrew came out and
said today that it is the same person. Now, I am fairly convinced
that basically someone in in Graham's campaign who was there
early, found out about the tattoo and let somebody know. They
connected with Lindsay Field and they concocted a scheme to make
it look like basically she'd been knowing about this for a long
time. That's what it looks like to me. She participated and then
it didn't work and so they went and tried to come up with a new
scheme. They concocted a new scheme to try to derail his campaign.
Okay, that's what it looks like to me. So, this is the story
that that she is telling after the fact. We might go through
a couple of our other friends basically saying Graham was an
Graham was an was abusive but it's like well is that abusive
as in like he's lying about cheating and continue to cheat and
saying he'll change but then not changing like that is abusive.
That is that's probably a narcissist. It's probably a bad person
but he's sort of confessed to all of that and said that's who
I was when I got back from the military. I am a piece of I was
a piece of I tried to change to be better and I'm not even sure
that that's true. But at minimum
this is sort of baked into the candidate already.
Okay. So without further ado, still finding after all these years.
That's where we're picking up. Here we go. There's just a there's
a lot there's a lot to unpack here, guys. There's a lot to unpack
here. Let me just say
my initial reaction to the article
was that there were two things that really stuck out to me that
there was no corroboration on the harshest allegations has to
be one and the other thing that would stick out is that they
maybe that they backed up the toten cop story. I think I think
those
sorry those would be the two things that stuck out to me. I wonder
what would stick out to Hutch cuz really the the sourcing is
the biggest one. That is the biggest one that you have to go,
dude. This is actually kind of like this probably shouldn't be
coming out at all. Um,
number one was the physical abuse.
The idea of like grabbing her by the arm,
frequently grabbing her by the
throwing her in a room and like locking her in a room. These
are serious
It's difficult to vote to convict in this kind of a situation
based on the memories of a single.
>> So I think the K file thing I I would like to see if
he goes back and looks at the K file stuff at all cuz to me
when you see this woman that this is the second attempt from
the same person who had a tumultuous relationship who told all
of her friends how much she hated this guy. It's her second attempt
to try to take this campaign down.
I trust me and I say this as somebody who has watched the scorned
woman narrative be used to totally dismiss many women that I
think were actually victims of abuse. I have seen this happen
multiple times. Okay, so I am incredibly careful about using
the scorned woman defense on anybody. All right, I don't I understand
the weight of using it. I understand that it can be used against
people in a way that is totally totally escaping the truth. Right.
I am but I I want to make it clear that I'm like I've looked
into this. I'm aware of the facts and I do think there's a good
chance that's what's happening here. Okay. Person without other
corroboration in the article. So I understand some healthy degree
of skepticism, but I would not immediately reject
the accusations because of the politics of the person
making the accusations.
That is crazy. That is straight up MAGA. >> Wait, it's
not about her politics, though. It's about her job.
Like, like, I'm sorry. It's not MAGA to go, well, this person's
a longtime political operative who has actually taken the precise
opposite position on allegations like this at the last m moment
with no substantiation in the past. Like, that's I'm sorry. That's
it's not rejecting her cuz she's a conservative or a MAGA Republican
or anything like that. It's rejecting her because she has done
this as a job, right? It's And when you put a lot of these pieces
together, it looks bad. I think anyone who says, "I just wouldn't
trust a Republican woman with this." Yeah, I would obviously
denounce that. If you want to make points about how like, well,
I'm wary to believe this because of her job, I also think that's
I think that's okay. If you say, "I'm never going to believe
this from a Republican woman or a Republican operative." I also
think that's bad. I would say that I don't know if I'd call that
MAGA, but I would say that's bad. It's just like, dude, you got
to be careful about what you're suggesting here. I think Emma
Viglin maybe went a little too far with what she said, but most
of the other people I've seen striking a fairly reasonable tone.
How many times has a woman come forward to accuse Donald Trump
of
assault, impropriy, harassment,
and then MAGA found out that the woman was a Democrat and then
tried to use that to dismiss those allegations. We have seen
that happen literally dozens of times. You think those cases
are all real?
I just does Does does Hutch think there are dozens of legitimate
assault cases on Donald Trump?
I just like realistically
I I have a hard time believing that. Even though I think Trump's
a total monster, by the way, I just have a hard time believing
that there's like a hundred women he assaulted or whatever the
because there's been so many. He said dozens. I just have a hard
time believing that that's those are all legitimate cases. Even
the majority of them would be legitimate that you wouldn't be
getting caught and and like hung up in court over that. >> And
it was quite jarring
yesterday to see so many people
>> Yeah, Hutch is totally out to lunch on this. I listen
I've done my I've done my due diligence making sure that he's
not being making sure that I'm giving him a chance. He's already
on this. He's already an embarrassing loser on this. There's
so many people just don't Bro,
stop. Stop just engaging with Twitter. Engage with the facts.
Figure out what's going on. Who are you can see he's like barely
engaging with what's going on. He's just like, "There's so many
people on Twitter who are saying things I don't like and I have
to take the opposite position of them. Just go look at the facts,
bro. Go look at the facts, dog." >> Are ostensibly on the
progressive left. >> Okay. CNN Platiner's campaign just
announced raising $200,000 in a single day following the New
York Times article. Their best single fundraising day since Janet
Mills dropped out of the main Senate race.
Yeah, I don't think that's really that's a pretty low amount
of money to be meaningful. I get it that it's like their best
day or whatever,
but that's more of a headline to try to steady things to be honest
with you.
>> like I by the way I I I'm like obviously for Platiner
but to me it's just like that's obviously them attempting to
steady things >> to this woman's politics
as a reason to immediately dismiss the allegations. >> So
I've heard a lot of people pointing out that Hutch did something
very similar with Tara Reed.
Terara Reed who by the way I believe there's more substantiation
for Tara Reed's story with Joe Biden than there is for this lady's
story with Graham Platner.
That is crazy. That is
crazy.
Another word for it is gross.
Like this, you guys, is hella gross.
The New York Times story in Grand Platner is frankly one of the
most pathetic smear jobs I've ever seen. The claim is just unsettling
behavior. And they cite a literal Republican operative he used
to date. Okay,
but I I understand that he's saying literal Republican operative.
Do you think that's his only reason? Do you think that's Kyle's
only rationale for this?
>> It's not.
This is crazy.
>> Last night was dark on the timeline. Dark.
Very dark.
A gentleman by the name of Mason McCann said people like this
would be openly mocking Eugene Carol every day if they were on
the right.
And then Kyle Kolinsky responds by saying, "Good thing she told
the truth and this Republican
didn't."
That is a crazy thing to type out. It's like a pretty gross
horseshoe situation here. >> I Why can't he just look at
the evidence? Like what? I want to hear Hutch's opinion on the
evidence without him referencing Kyle Klinsky. I just want Hutch
to give me his opinion on >> Just bananas. I mean, he was
working
>> This was working overtime on Twitter. In fact, he drew
some battle lines. He said any liberal who basically lends any
kind of credence to this story is a traitor
or some such. >> I mean certainly to blue matter. >> I'm
sorry man. Kyle Kolinsky is an actual disgusting piece of >> like
just a genuinely disgusting piece >> says you literally
literally says you buddy. Says you.
>> Uh new MAGA platner smear falls apart instantly. Trump
crashes out as Congress rebukes Iran war. We don't need to watch
>> What's up, y'all? Got a bunch of breaking news here
for you that I wanted to talk about. Uh, obviously the big thing
is that here they go again. Here they go again, y'all. The New
York Times decided to put together yet another hit piece on Graham
Platner. Uh, except this one. Uh, I don't think anybody's buying
this one, but I really think that like over 90% of people are
looking at it going, "That's it. That's all you got." So, there's
a bunch of hype leading to this where people >> I mean,
certainly everybody on his follow, everybody in his network sure
>> online were speculating like, "Oh, oh, it's gonna be
bad. Oh, well, it's going to be it." And you had honestly widespread
speculation that it was going to be assault. And, um, when it
came out, it isn't even close to assault and it is the most underwhelming
thing I've ever seen. So I have to jump here. Let me just say
if you have a New York Times subscription, it's honestly time
to cancel it because they are at this point basically campaigning
for Susan Collins. >> This is just I mean come on. This
is just mega inverse. This is just Blue Ma.
>> Just just straight up blue MAGA. You know, like [clears throat]
>> I I think this was this piece was like journalistic
malpractice.
I I do think that this piece was like it was weird that this
piece got published. I'm not even joking. Like this piece was
actually pretty rough. >> I'm not going to cancel my New
York Times subscription because I do think they do the best profiles.
like their BB Netanyahu profile on him convincing Trump to go
to war. Like second to none. So I'm sorry that they do a lot
of good journalism that is not necessarily their journalism to
do with I guess Graham Platner and his campaign. I'm not cancelling,
but I I do get quite frustrated seeing this article published
and
how things like sort of fell apart. That makes more sense to
me because they must have decided they needed to go with it or
run with it now that they teased it and stuff. But man, oh man,
it was uh I I just don't think there was a story
>> I can understand um and respect someone being uh somewhat
skeptical. That's fine. I I truly understand that. Um there's
not a ton of information to go off of. I, you know, it's uh for
me when I look at sort of the whole breadth of like everything
we've learned about this guy. Like none of it would shock me.
Um but I wouldn't vote to convict a court of law, I lean towards
believing the the stories in that article with the with the understanding
as well that um you know, her perspective might be a little skewed
one way. And so that you know, I even I have like some degree
of skepticism that I think is fine. there's just no evidence
for any of the things said. So like while you basically like
I understand what Hutch is saying
and maybe we're not that far apart but like you don't hold it
against the person if there if it's like well I could maybe believe
it because I have a bias against this guy but then you you can't
say okay well he shouldn't run for the Senate now
right I also want to say that um I believe that people [clears throat]
can go through that kind of a period of their life and come out
the other side and become a better person and and turn their
life around. And I genuinely believe that Grant Platiner is uh
probably on a better path than he was before. Which not to say
that he is perfect because we found out he was sexing a dozen
women like last year. But I do believe that people can change.
I do believe that we don't. >> Now it's just a dozen. It's
not 6 to 12 anymore. Now it's a dozen. Now it's a full baker.
>> You can condemn people for the rest of their lives based
on the sins of their past. All that said, this isn't about any
moral condemnation of >> All that said, >> let's
condemn this for the sins of his past. All that said, let's take
this down. Ramper, this is about deciding whether or not somebody
is qualified to hold one of the highest offices in the country.
Like, is this somebody that I would feel comfortable giving that
kind of power to? >> I know my answer that to that question,
but it's not a moral condemnation of Grand P. >> I see
Tallybots in the chat. What indication do we have that he has
changed? Tallybot votes. Tallybots votes entirely on one issue.
It's her identity. That's the only thing she votes on. That's
the only thing she cares about. I just I have no respect for
people who vote this way. It's all identity politics for you.
Off >> planner. I mean, when I read the story, my honest
reaction was knowing just what he himself has said about his
life as a veteran who struggled struggled with PTSD. None of
it shocked me, you know, truly like none of it. I read it, I
was like, "Yeah, that's going to go right."
>> It happened in 2023 and 2024, I think this, so technically
a year and a half, two years ago. >> Um, the physical stuff
is bad. She she made it a point to um clarify that he didn't
hit her, but the physical stuff is bad.
>> Uh, and I also think it's not something that I would
like
>> ever just like refuse to like forgive someone for, you
know, like I think I just I know people who have been physical
when they were with their spouses when they were when they were
um addicted to substances. I've seen people talk about these
experiences. I've seen people express deep remorse and guilt
and I've seen partners like actually, you know, survive and and
come out and be like better better um a better couple, stronger
couple. So, I just, you know, truly truly truly I believe that
you don't get to run for the Senate. If Grant Platner were wanting
to be a streamer, I would support that entirely, but he can't
run for the Senate. >> Nope. I just want to put that out
there. Like none of this stuff to me, I'm not reading this thinking
he's this like irred irred irred irredeemable piece of that's
not what any of my anger and frustration is about at this point
probably 50% of my anger and frustration are with people like
>> it's it's been a jarring experience
if 50% of your frustration is with Kyle then you don't believe
anything in the article if 50% of your frustration is with Kyle
and this couldn't have possibly moved you on whether or not this
guy is actually going to run for the Senate. I read I I thought
this guy does assault and I read that he was physically abusive,
but 50% of my problem is with people like Kyle.
>> What? Truly, it's been a jarring experience watching
this corner of the internet essentially just mirror MAGA in their
logic while defending this guy who, let's just be clear, he's
just some guy. He's just some guy that we all became aware of,
you know, like seven months ago.
And they're defending him harder than I've ever seen I've ever
seen them defend a candidate. It is so bizarre to me. Does Hutch
not understand that this is just the inverse of and
like he had the talk with Josiah. I need to go clip up that talk
with Josiah so that Hutch can always come back to the same thing.
Right? Do you understand that you on lefties constantly for being
upset for the moral crime of abetting a genocide? a far heavier,
far weightier crime than anything Grand Platiner is even still
accused of that you have like no leg to stand on here in terms
of virtue signaling. If you are against them being upset about
Kamla, not wanting to vote for Kamala to remain uncommitted,
you you automatically lose. You automatically lose right
now with Platner.
Oh man, with this stuff, I don't believe it with the tattoo and
stuff. It's like, okay, I think you still vote for him unambiguously
at this point. Okay. Anyway, we keep watching. It is so bizarre
to me. Like I feel like if you could if you have a time machine
and you know go back to the to to the time that like we all saw
his first campaign ad and if you could just add everything that
we've learned about this guy, you know, after let's just say
like you know we we we rewind the clock 8 n months ago whenever
his first campaign ad came out and you know if we could go back
and like use the time machine and after the first time that everybody
saw his ad, somebody would come in and just tell you okay like
here's what we found out about this guy in the next like 8 months
and just list every bad story. People in that moment would be
like okay probably shouldn't go with this guy. But because it's
it's happened gradually over time, it just it's like building
a tolerance for a drug addict. It's like the the Kyle Kolinsky
in the media space and all that. All all of the strongest >> I
I really think like a lot of it was just built into the candidate,
right? He ran as a candidate who had a flawed past. So when this
stuff came out,
right, when all of this stuff came out, it was like, okay, he
said he was flawed. Like really, you know, is this that far off
from what a lot of people would say if they never thought somebody
would see the messages? No. Like what? He thinks black people
don't tip. I I'm sorry if he could at least acknowledge that,
hey, that's based on, you know, it's kind of like a racist trope.
I It's really not that big a deal. >> Platinum Defenders,
they've just little by little they've built up more of a tolerance
to his bad stories. And so at this point, I think like literally
anything could come out. It could, you know, it could come out
that he like killed a kid or, you know, essayed someone or whatever,
but they're so >> No, no,
dude. I
It's like he's watched my streams on him and how he acts and
he's like just trying to reapply that same criticism at this
point.
They've already just committed so much to this guy. And so I
I just think they're going to they're they're just Yeah, they're
just
>> I truly think it would be difficult to find like a disqualifying
thing for Graham Platner with respect to the Senate like that
that he's continued to pull ahead that he's continued to win
the primary, right? that he's basically assuing to win the primary.
There's there's no other possibility, right?
There is no other candidate. If there was another candidate,
we could have this conversation. There literally isn't a candidate.
Dan Mills ain't it, bro. >> Deep in it at this point. They're
just way too deep. >> No matter who, Epstein, segregationist.
Yeah, it's um Hutch used to understand this that the the Trump
problem is the is the real problem. Hutch used to get it and
now he because a candidate that was once supported by Hassan
[__] is going to win the main primary. Hutch will
abandon all things he previously thought, all things he previously
Ooh,
Hutch is getting trolled as well. United Auto Workers Union endorsed
Abdul Sayad. That's big for Michigan. Yes, it is. In fact, Michigan
may be cooked. We're what? Three days, four days away from that
primary right now. I think we're four days away, right? It's
Yeah, I think it's Tuesday the 9th is that primary in Michigan.
Yeah, I think that primary is cooked. I think Elsa is starting
to run away with that one. I think she's I think she's cooked.
I think it's over in Michigan. I think Elsa's going to be the
candidate in Michigan. No, >> like I was looking at my
feed last night. All these people who ostensively present themselves
as like these
>> are all just like basically
>> telling everyone that you should
>> ignore the allegations from this woman because she's
a conservative
>> now. I saw a lot of people attacking her reputation.
Ryan Grim, Emma Vigland, Kyle Klinsky, Crystal Ball, they all
attacked her reputation, right?
>> But
like I have a hard time I don't know what I should do cuz to
me I like to have all the information. I like to be able to make
the point that we're going after her reputation because it is
a valid concern with regards to the story. Not because I'm saying,
"Oh, look at her reputation." I'm not just jangling keys and
saying, "Look at her reputation. Look at her her advocacy. This
is she's a bad person, right?" I'm not trying to do that. I'm
saying that like there's a genuine concern that involves her
previous occupation, her political advocacy. Like there's a genuine
concern here. I'm not just jangling keys. And I get how for Hutch
he's saying he thinks that Hal Kinslinsky, Crystal Ball, Ryan
Grim, all these people are just doing that. I don't think so.
I'd like to think that they have a little more information. They're
not just jangling keys, but they know that the way they're posting
about it is the way to get the m the information to cut through.
I think that's what's going on there, but I'm not totally sure.
Okay,
it's bananas.
What they're telling you is that
I if if there was a universe where Grand Platner
was physically abusive to ex-girlfriends and some of them were
uh and the ones that came forward were Republicans,
they'll never believe those women. That's crazy to me, you guys.
>> I don't think they're saying that at all. I think they're
saying given the the evidence in the story, there's no reason
to believe it,
>> right? I don't I don't think a single person there,
not even not even the worst of them, is saying, "Oh, well, I
don't care if this got hit, right? They're saying there's no
evidence that this actually happened. And because there's no
evidence that it happened, and because of her occupation, her
history as a Republican operative, I don't trust this, so I'm
not going to look at it."
>> That's insane to me. I can I can understand some degree
of skepticism. Again, some degree. I understand
there's a lot of allegations that are being made. It's fine to
reserve like full judgment
before you >> Well, you don't have to have any judgment,
right? >> You have enough information to feel like rock
solid about it. That's fine. But >> all right, separating,
does he? Hutch just likes Hutch just likes, you know, preaching
to the choir. That's why I almost banned that that one from yesterday,
the day before, and I decided not to. I'm just letting a lot
of the stay now because >> honestly if they're going to
actually argue once in a while then it's fine. It's good. >> God,
you are so distracting. Tara Reed, there's no way. Tara Reed.
Oh my goodness. Okay.
Tara Reed, who defected to Russia and then accused the Biden
administration and Interpole of wanting to murder her. Tara Reed.
Don't get me started on Tara Reed. Um
just because she's in Russia means you can't trust her at all.
So even if she was like brutally by Joe Biden, because she's
in Russia, you would just like let that go. You wouldn't care
if there was a lot of evidence for it. Do you see how this line
of thinking, this line of like argumentation is hutch? Do you
see how stupid I sound when I speak like that? Do you see how
stupid you sound when you speak like that? Right. I don't think
he means that. I think he means given that the the lack of substantiation,
given the lack of information, I'm not sure that we can trust
it given, you know, she's defected.
just exactly what Kyle's saying, which is exactly what Crystal's
saying, which is exactly what Ryan Grim is saying. >> Hutch
just did the exact same thing.
>> But he doesn't see it. He doesn't
>> He lacks
>> He lacks second order thought. He can't see how the
statements he makes collide with the other statements he's made.
He can't see it. It's never once occurred to him. Hey, I just
said something that actually totally undercuts the point I was
making. It doesn't occur. It doesn't it it doesn't exist in his
brain. He doesn't even see it. >> But that that is what
they're saying, right? Like that like they're they're saying
if it's a Republican that come forward that comes forward and
and accuses a candidate they like of some kind of abuse, you
can just dismiss them. You can just dismiss the al
like it's wild.
He just did the same thing. Now I will say that obviously being
a Republican is far less egregious than defecting to another
country. But what the the woman is a Republican crystal ball
uncorroborated
uncorroborated accusations
critical element to this sentence saying there is no corroboration
to these accusations. There is no corroboration here >> Times
published an uncorroborated accusations against Graham formain
of unsettling and toxic behavior that came from a heritage staffer
who previously worked for a conservative org that backed Collins.
It's bananas. It is
What does he think uncorroborated means?
Not a consistent principle. They want it to be platiner because
they like his politics and they've deluded themselves into thinking
that he can just continue to survive story after story after
story. Uh Jug Runner for $5. Just curious, what's your opinion
on Ashley Biden's diary?
Um my opinion is I listen to Ashley Biden herself. I mean people
process all kinds of stuff privately in their diary. That's that's
so insane to me that Republican operatives like found her diary
somehow. >> That's like way different. That's way different.
That's way different. Hold on. That's way way way different.
That's way Hold on. Hold on, dude. [laughter]
Dude, that's crazy.
>> Don't trust that child. Listen,
I understand that that child says the bishop raped him, but that
child is a child. I'm going to listen to if that child turns
into an adult and they want to say that the bishop them, then
maybe. But we're not going to listen to that child right now.
Shut the [__] up. Shut >> Jug Runner for $5.
Just curious, what's your opinion on Ashley Biden's diary?
Um, my opinion is I listen to Ashley Biden herself. I mean, people
process all kinds of stuff privately in their diary. That's that's
so insane to me that Republican operatives like found her diary
somehow and like that's crazy to me. But she herself commented
on that. She never alleged that Joe Biden abus her. Buller with
$5, the same guy who would not mind Platner texting his mom,
by the way. True. Alexis with $5. One layer to this is that leftists
thrive on the feeling that they are morally superior to everyone
else. They can never admit they were wrong. I would rather they
just be honest and be like, "Yeah, he's there are problems with
this guy, but I like his politics and I'm not going to vote for
Collins." I can stomach that. Truly, I can I can stomach that.
But don't don't gaslight me and everybody else by insisting that
there's no there there. Like he isn't this like really messy
candidate. Like there aren't super valid
reasons to doubt his character or doubt his ability to beat Susan
Collins, who at one point in the last race that she was in defending
that seat was.
>> Hutch is actually just going to try to submarine as
many Dems as he can. This is so funny.
Also, the the whole um the whole Susan Collins like overp performed
her polls last time, that is the most brain damaged
libed up talking point. Holy, you need to end your
political advocacy on the internet. Okay? Cuz my god is the is
the status quo ever not in favor right now. This long-term politician
who's shown that she basically has a neurocognitive dis neurodeenerative
disease. She very likely has some neurodeenerative disease. Okay?
And she's shown that on camera. The fact that you think that's
a good candidate, that that candidate's going to be able to go
against Platiner in a general election, you're out of your mind.
Okay? She's not overperforming polls this time. I I hate to tell
it to you, okay? I hate to say it to you, she's obviously not
going to overperform her polls in the worst economy that's existed
in the entire time she's been a politician. >> Susan Collins
was down by over 20 points >> at one point in her last
race, and she came back and she won that race by like eight points.
You don't understand how formidable she is. She is one of the
most resilient campaigners.
>> This is the guy who literally can't update his opinions,
right? Who thought you had to stick with Biden. He's just too
stupid to process new information and actually integrate that
into his model in the entire Congress.
>> And people are like, "Oh yeah, well Flat was up four
points in an internal poll last week or two days ago." Uh, it's
fine. Chat box with 200 bits. I do not say this lightly. I say
this exactly as damning as it sounds. Kyle looks and sounds and
is acting like techone here. This reaction to essay allegations
against the populist.
[screaming] Dude, what? Okay. Can we just be more serious? Can
we just be any amount more serious than this?
Looks like Get the out of here. These people don't even know
Teone,
dude. Hutch doesn't even know Teone. Democrat. Well, to be clear,
there were no SA allegations in the New York Times article. The
main accuser is alleging that there were women or are women that
have accused him of essay, but for some reason that wasn't in
the story. That is what she is saying. Just privately behind
the scenes like this has been kind of an open secret. People
have been talking about there have been rumors and murmurss about
essay allegations and even specific aspects of essay allegations
that like I even became made aware of by relatively reliable
sources. >> Oh, please.
What are those relatively reliable sources?
What are those relatively reliable sources that are leaking you
Oh my god. I
sorry. I
I almost dropped a fantastic [__] right there. I
was like I was right there on the edge. I just like my brain
had to reset for a second. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine.
>> Those didn't come out in the story. Maybe they don't
come out ever, but you know, the the woman in the article claims
that she is actually like um connected with like she's speaking.
She's in correspondence with she's talking with uh women that
have other accusations. It's just insane behavior to immediately
dismiss allegations because of the person's politics. That's
ins
that didn't happen.
Like I if he can look at that crystal ball tweet and say that
that's crystal ball dismissing the allegations because of the
person's political affiliation, he's illiterate. He's like actually
just illiterate. He's worthless as a political advocate. He's
worthless as a political influencer.
Right. She literally says, "The problem with this stuff is that
there's unsubstantiated allegations coming from a Republican
Unsubstantiated allegations, uncorroborated allegations.
That's the problem."
Sane,
we live in a universe where Republican women with political opinions
that I loathe
are victims of abuse. Republican women are victims of abuse.
They get abused just like liberal women, just like leftist women.
Of course they do. Why would we immediately dismiss allegations
because of someone's politics? That is crazy. And just the opposite
of what we've and just like all of these creators, it's just
so what you need here is Hutch reading the crystal ball tweet
and then you need all the times where he just keeps saying that
this is the only thing she cares about here is that it's a Republican.
The only thing she cares about here is that it's a Republican,
right? over and over and over again when she clearly says uncorroborated
accusations.
That is clearly her primary issue,
right? So he is just making this up as he goes.
So you need all of his times making this up, pretending that
crystal ball did this. He is illiterate. He is incompetent and
he just people have to post about it. People have to talk about
it. He's worthless. Okay. them and became like a little Republican.
But then like
just like you should you should obviously not immediately
>> dismiss allegations if they come from a Republican woman
and it's about a candidate that you like. Why does this need
to be explained? >> And as I told you guys, this is what
happens when you stand up to the oligarchy, when you stand up
to the military-industrial complex. When you stand up to the
Israel lobby, they will stop at nothing to destroy you. Here's
the title. Several women who dated Graham Platner recall unsettling
Unsettling behavior.
>> Come on, man. Really? This is what we're doing in 2020.
I I hate this guy. I hate
>> Why? Because he's Bro,
you Hutch. You compared unsettling behavior to actual allegations
with like civil suits of assault. You understand? You're out
of your mind, right? You're out of your bold skull. >> I
hate this guy so much. He is the actual worst. I don't understand.
Uh he's just the worst. >> The president is a and a and
defending the entire Epstein class. And you're talking about
how Graham Platner had unsettling behavior, but it gets better.
Ready? So the >> you know, you just like grab your girlfriend
by the arm and people just get you lock them in a room and people
just get so upy about it. It's
>> unsubstantiated,
uncorroborated allegation.
Zero corroboration.
And yes, that is way less bad than assault or kids. Obviously,
Hutch, I know you want to make it similar to kids, but it's >> It's
like, come on, live a little. The main person they site who has
like the worst stories about Graham is a literal Republican operative.
I'm not kidding. [laughter] I'm not kidding. Is a literal Republican
operative. Worked for the Heritage Foundation. Worked on some
anti-trans thing. Literally said, "I'm going to campaign for
Susan Collins." Self-describes as a bitter ex.
He is so bad at his job. He is so bad at his job. He's the laziest
guy on the internet, bro. This guy is so lazy. In the article,
she said, >> "I can't that. No way.
No way.
It's just the most insane mirror posting that I have to deal
with." I know it seems like I'm this bitter ex-girlfriend, but
I'm not. She specifically says she's not. He says the opposite.
He is so lazy and reckless and careless and just like just the
worst. Did he >> Oh, did she she said I'm not just a bitter
ex. I think she says something about trying to avoid that. Unfortunately,
she is a bitter ex. Like, like all of the all of her words point
you to that she's a bitter ex. All of my friends know I've been
talking about how abusive Graham was for years. Yeah, you've
been this guy like obviously in a bad relationship and you've
like complained about him to multiple people.
A bitter ex. By the way, you can be a bitter exter.
All it's saying is you probably can't look at that person objectively.
You could have a legitimately bad relationship that the other
person's 95% at fault for and be a bitter ex. >> Even read
the article. We all know the answer to that question. >> You
you can't make this up. Like you literally can't make this up.
The fact that this ran in the New York Times the New York Times
is acting functionally as no different than Fox News when it
comes to the race in Maine. Okay. This is B. >> Does that
mean he was functionally no different from Fox News for the 2016
and 2020 election cycle? >> Is that what he's saying? >> This
is like an inkind contribution to Susan Collins is what we're
witnessing here. again the conflation of the the moral
wrong in supporting a genocide
basically saying I need to see more evidence from this Republican
operative
other than like unsubstantiated uncorroborated allegations. So
written by a massive Israel lobby insider. Okay. The main claims
come from a literal Republican operative and the most they could
have come up with the worst way to describe it is he had unsettling
behavior. Please spare me. So, by the way, I'll just say upfront,
there's a lot of like quotes that are in the piece from the Republican
operative that are just like completely and utterly made up.
Like, she made up that he said certain things completely and
utterly made up. Okay. I hope not. I I hope he sat there was
like, "It's all about power, and if a robber ever breaks in here,
I'm going to them in a non-gay, nonsexual way to show dominance."
I hope he said, "That's funny." Okay. I'm sorry. That's funny.
>> I don't even know what he is talking about there, >> but
let's put those things aside cuz again, no allegations of assault.
No allegations of no allegations of anything like that. No allegations
of assault or anything uh physically violent by any stretch of
the imagination. Here's one of my favorite parts of it. Uh they
go on to say >> we just glossed over the fact like this
>> that is a little too far from Kyle there. I would say
>> maybe if you want to say not physical assault but like
physical coercion, physical manipulation.
Like it's not I don't know if you'd call it assault, but pushing
somebody into a room like that is obviously
>> it's tough to take that seriously. >> That's got
to be a way to like get away with abuse or something, isn't it?
Is like if you just push somebody into a room and you like lock
them in there. It's I can't think of a scenario where I've seen
that happen where I feel like
it's been because
the person who's locked in the room is the cooler head. But I
I bet that does work, right? I bet that I bet there are people
who are like coercive in that exact way. So I should I shouldn't
mock it. It's just to me it's like I understand that there's
like a fight that's probably getting like into pushing on some
in some way on both sides and eventually that's what happens,
right? Thousand%.
And we already this was already obvious, but like this 1,000%
shows us that he is just very plainly lying that he didn't know
what the tattoo was.
incredibly damning
>> of assault or anything physically violent by any stretch
of the imagination. Here's one of my favorite parts of it. Uh
they go on to >> We just glossed over the fact like this
and we already this was already obvious, but like this 1,000%
shows us that he is just very plainly lying that he didn't know
what the tattoo was.
>> I'm sorry. I should stream in the morning and I should
just take this guy's slot. I could take this guy's slot. I would
take this guy's slot. He is too stupid. He's too stupid to be
allowed to continue at the rate he's going. I could easily I
I have to be able to take his right.
>> I don't make these mistakes.
I don't I am better than this guy at this specific job.
He's going to say that this is a different corroboration on the
same on that exact story, right? He's saying this story proves
that he was just lying about the tattoo.
>> Incredibly damning that she was in a private text group
with her friends two months before the story came out calling
it his totem comp.
That is really damning. I mean it was obvious that he's been
lying about this for a long time. Uh it was already obvious but
this is just you know like that's just dead to rights. >> Okay.
Or you know one of them goes on to say uh oh he had he would
keep an >> going to bring up the other article. around
his DC apartment when he lived in DC. He would keep an assault
weapon around. And and another one is, oh, he would sharpen an
ax. Am I supposed to read that and be
>> Oh, thank you. Thank you, Hutch. Is this the same person
who corroborated that he knew it was a toteen cop or is this
now a second person? >> Oh, dare. That's disqualifying.
The ex-soldier keeps around an AR-15 and sharpens an axe. How
dare he? Like, who is this for? What is this doing? What is going
on? >> Oh, is he not going to I still haven't gotten to
this part. So, in the article, where the worst they can come
up with to say in the title is that he had unsettling behavior.
They speak to multiple of his girlfriends and a whole bunch of
them were like, "Oh, he's a gentle giant. He's like, you know,
one of the sweetest guys I ever dated." He's >> What a
cheat code, you guys. Kyle just gave you the cheat code. Okay,
young men. Okay,
>> okay, hang on. I want to be careful here. Um, >> I'm
not going to frame this as advice. That's that's that's important
taste. According to Kyle standards,
uh you know what's epic? If you ever do something like this,
you will feel shame and show up to apologize for misleading your
audience. Imagine that.
I hope so.
>> By the way, even when I was going through and saying
like, I suspect that this is the case, I'm like looking at the
timelines. I'm making sure they match up. And then I basically
I instead of saying that this is obviously the case, I say I
suspect this is the case. And then I at the author on Twitter,
right? I at the author on Twitter and I say, "Dude, this is like
pretty weird that the these seem to align one to one. They seem
to be the same story." Are they the same story? >> Guy
who uh is abusive to women in previous relationships. Uh, if
you can find a few exes that say that they had good experiences
with you, you're good. That's what he's saying.
You can get out of it. You can discredit your accusers. If you
can find two or three, preferably three, even one probably would
be fine. But if you can find a few exes that you had pleasant
experiences with, you're off the hook. There you go. They couldn't
help themselves. My guess is they were trying to cover their
ass from litigation. That's my guess is that they realize that
like, okay, we're really we're taking the word of a Republican
operative and an Israel lobby hack is writing this. We're going
to have to cover our bases so we don't get sued. And so like
they ended up talking to multiple of his ex-girlfriends and most
of them were like, "Oh yeah, he's actually a like perfectly sweet
guy. You know, never felt in danger in any way, shape, or form
around him. As I said, Gentle Giant," I believe was a quote that
one of them used. So in the literal hippie, they're also like,
"And also like he's a good guy." You know what I'm saying? Like
[laughter] come on, man. Come on. Yeah, exactly, Kilo. Right.
That that is exactly it. It's like, okay, not reading the article
and speaking on it. I don't even know what's worse. They're both
bad. Maybe not reading, but but still reads the article and he
can't comprehend. He like doesn't get it. I don't understand
how immediately when you go to look at this article, it's it's
at this pivotal moment in this race. I did this with the Swallowwell
stuff, right? I knew that it was incredibly important. You have
to actually go through and see because if somebody's dropping
something last minute, there is a very high chance that it is
purely for political gain, purely for a political reason, right?
And so I was careful reading this wall stuff. I was trying to
be fair to him, very fair to him, maybe even too fair to him.
And with the with the Platiner stuff, it's very similar. Like,
okay, there's
totally uncorroborated allegations from somebody who has already
tried to tank his campaign once. We done with Kyle. I think we're
done with Kyle. I'm not I'm probably not going to do all of the
rest of this, but there's a Ryan Grim part that comes up in a
little bit that I think is pretty good. And then we'll
>> about 15 minutes here. >> Serious of an allegation.
Use the bathroom. Why are we digging into past relationships
from over a decade a from you know years ago? Um and if it is
a serious allegation
then how are we printing this without any corroboration given
the likely the the clear-cut political motivation here? Um and
you know as a >> the clearcut political motivation again
you would need more than the fact that this woman is a Republican.
You would need some kind of pattern of behavior
>> to indicate that this would be >> If only Hutch
had paid any attention. If only Hutch had paid any attention
at all.
If only Hutch had paid any attention, he wouldn't be lost right
now >> in line with her character. So far, I have not seen
that.
The the the logic here is that because she's a rep Republican,
there's a there's a clear there's a clear political motivation.
There could be, but you would have to corroborate that. He would
need more than just like they have different politics than me.
>> As I said before, he completely >> FDR and mex
suit with $5. Nobody seems to be asking if anything worse is
coming out if they are trickling this. Is there something worse
in their back pocket? Does anyone in my chat right now, Platiner
defenders or platiner attackers? Does anyone seriously think
that this is going to be the last story that comes out about
this guy?
>> No. No person believes this. Everybody understands like
this
this kind of a person with this kind of a past
and and given everything the way that he's inviting more scrutiny
with the crazy lies with the with the insane denials and lies
just generally and so that invites more scrutiny. Now other journalists
they see blood in the water. This guy is like
a gold mine of stories. And so now you're going to
I like I agree with Hutch, but I I think he's been this for quite
a while that people have been looking into him. I >> I
think the first indication of this is that story being set up
to run on October. I think that's the first indication that this
is this guy was like basically had was having ops run on
And it's been that way for a while. And I do think this story
was like their Hail Mary to get him to drop out because again,
like I've already laid out my whole thoughts on this, right?
That I think they know he's going to win the general. They know
that he can't be stopped. They know that Susan Collins is like
a lost cause.
I think I think that's not going to come out in polling yet.
I think we get one debate between these two and Susan Collins
is obliterated. I don't think it's close. I'm not joking. you
won debate and Susan Collins has to go and do her stupid status
quo rhetoric when this guy goes up and talks about how hospitals
are closing, how they're getting over by the Trump administration,
how Trump's personally arrandized himself, made himself massively
wealthy through corruption, and Susan Collins barely has spoken
about it. Dude, it's a done deal. It's over. Yeah, $5, dude.
It's so over. She wouldn't vote. She didn't vote to uh enact
the first war powers resolution. Done deal. over.
She's She's so vulnerable and it's only because they're not in
the general yet that she's not getting attacked.
It's whoever the Dem nominee is, I think, is going to have an
easy time,
I think. But he's just the guy who's going to win the
And so they're trying to get him to drop out. That's the pressure
campaign is to get him to drop out. And I think he knows that
if he just holds step holds holds fast. Yeah. Holds fast, he's
going to be fine. >> Uh Alexis, with $5, the Trump deflection
is upsetting. There's always a man out there that has done worse.
I It's just the wor That's the worst one. It's just like we shouldn't
even be talking about Grand Platter when Donald Trump is president.
That's crazy because you could use that to excuse anything.
Congrats. You've just been given like a like a permanent I win
card. If any if any bad news comes out about some candidate you
don't like. All you got to do is just say, "Okay, well, Donald
Trump is president." And then you can just ignore every red flag
about that.
>> Bro, I'm so sorry.
>> H I just so many people have done this exact defense
and I do feel like I don't know if Hutch engaged in it. So Hutch
might be off the hook, but so many people around Hutch have used
this precise defense. >> That's my those are my thoughts
that I'll sort of leave us with. Um and I'll let you guys continue
on. You can talk about the tattoo and all the things, but um
but you know that's where I get angry. this is near the end >> in
this story is it's not that they're you know that it's not unreasonable
to report on Graham and his struggles and his past and whatever
but when you see how selectively this level of scrutiny is applied
and the type of things they will print about him that I do not
think they would print about you know a Chuck Schumer if you
had a similar
ideologically motivated allegation against him that's where it
I think is very biased and in I
>> I just don't know why he he laughs before listening.
Like he he actually can't pay attention and listen and hear what's
being said. Like I I don't know how many more times I could say
just like you should probably listen to other people in the room
cuz you you can't handle this. Like you should message other
people. I I'll just say it again. Actually, just go watch Josiah's
videos. Just beat Josiah on a delay and you'd be so much better
at this. >> Opinion egregious.
>> I don't even know what this is. like, well, if Chuck
Schumer was caught a dozen women and if he had a Nazi tattoo
and if he uh had an old Reddit account that he baff bafflingly
just didn't think to delete up until just recently, uh you know,
if he had a public uh kick profile where he was, you know, very
conveniently
covering the only tattoo that happened to be a Nazi tattoo after
he denied knowing that it was a Nazi tattoo and even though we
have multiple other people that are saying he knew that it was
a Nazi tattoo and if he uh allegedly um you know physically abused
an ex-girlfriend and um was deeply misogynistic and you know
had some really dark and uh you know unsettling behavior if all
those things happened and and this was Chuck Schumer. Ah they
wouldn't have they is she seriously saying this right now? >> You
compare this to serious right now.
>> Compared it to a guy who's his staffers as a politician.
yesterday. I'm positive he compared it to Swallwell. So, he's
he's acting like this is not actually this is not the same. It's
not even close. And it's like, dude, it's
equally far away. Well, maybe not from Chuck Schumer because
Chuck Schumer
>> can't even get his card anymore. But,
>> listen, it's it's also ball it's like a different universe,
different ballpark entirely. Okay. Do you think that if the media
found out that Chuck Schumer was a dozen women that they wouldn't
report on
>> Does she seriously believe that?
>> There's no The media barely reports on Susan Collins
basically marrying
the person she was cheating with while that person's wife was
in terminal like cancer treatment. That that doesn't even get
talked about. Happened in like 2013. People barely know about
that >> way. If the if the media found out that Chuck Schumer
had a Nazi tattoo, she thinks that they would sit on that story.
Is she insane? Is she actually insane? You don't think that they
would have pounced on that just the same?
Not if it was uncroborated.
The texting maybe, but the uncorroborated story. No.
No, they wouldn't. There would be
You don't You don't go with uncooperated on just anybody. You
just you flat out
>> What a delusional thing to say. That is completely insane.
>> that's crazy.
Chucky boy would be chased out of the party with pitchfork for
forks within
It's not just that they wouldn't look into it, right? It's not
just they wouldn't look into it. It's that they would need some
some corroboration. You wouldn't run a big story on a big politician
with no corroboration.
The New York Times wouldn't. Maybe a rag would, maybe a Twitter
account would, but the New York Times would not.
48 hours. If any single one of those stories was reported on,
if it was a Nazi tattoo, he'd be out. If he was a dozen women,
he'd be out. If he had allegations of physical abuse from ex-girlfriends,
he'd be pushed out of the party within 48 hours. We are going
to look back on this moment in history, and it's just so absurd.
Everything about this moment and everything about this candidate
and everything about their reaction to him is absurd.
Completely absurd and obviously wildly hypocritical. It betrays
a total lack of principles when it comes to these issues.
They never had any principles about these. It's just it's about
the politics of the accuser and that's it.
>> Cool. All right. We got it. We got it. We got it. We
got it. Nailed it.